Bienvenidos a la sección económica de
France 24 y lo hacemos de la mano de
Daniela hablando Daniela bienvenida
Muchas gracias María Clara Daniela
Cuántas horas puede trabajar usted
semanalmente puedo trabajar muchas pero
aproximadamente entre 35 38 horas Bueno
pues esa es la pregunta crucial que
están haciendo en Chile donde se aprobó
una ley para rebajar las horas semanales
Así es pues tras seis años de discusión
chile promulgó esta ley que permitirá
reducir la jornada laboral máxima de 45
a 40 horas semanales esta iniciativa es
catalogada de histórica Aunque es una
recomendación que desde hace seis
décadas viene haciendo la organización
Internacional del trabajo y que al mismo
tiempo abre un debate sobre la
productividad el país austral es ahora
el segundo de América Latina solamente
después de Ecuador en aprobar este tope
de horario ustedes mencionaba que chile
la idea de llegar a 40 horas laborales
cada semana pero esto en promedio Cómo
es la comparación en la región Pues en
el otro extremo hay naciones como México
Argentina o Perú que establecen límites
que promedian las 48 horas Colombia en
cambio Si aprobó una iniciativa similar
a la de chile para reducir su carga en
horas de trabajo para llevarla de 48 a
42 horas también será gradual por
supuesto Este cambio comienza en julio
próximo y va hasta 2026 en Chile también
habrá una transición escalonada de 5
años con una serie de incentivos también
para que las empresas no esperen tanto
tiempo para dar este paso así lo explicó
la diputada Carol cariola una de las
promotoras del proyecto
el plazo que se puso en la ley es un
plazo de cinco años para su
implementación total esto significa que
una vez iniciada en vigencia que ya
entró en vigencia cuando pase un año
está la obligatoriedad de bajar a 44
horas cuando pasen dos años está la
obligación de bajar a cuarenta y tres y
cuando pasen tres años cuarenta y dos y
al quinto año finalmente la rebaja
obligatoria es a cuarenta Estos son
plazos máximos de obligatoriedad pero no
significa que los plazos de
implementación necesariamente tengan que
estar regidos por esta Norma hay
empresas que ya se han adelantado y que
por lo tanto podemos decir que la rebaja
de la jornada laboral es algo que ya se
está implementando en Chile a partir de
estas más de quinientas empresas que han
decidido adquirir este sello cuarenta
horas y como están respondiendo los
privados a estas iniciativas Pues en el
caso chileno esta ley recibió muchas
críticas y hasta burlas cuando fue
presentada porque se tiene la percepción
general de que al menos horas laborales
afectan la productividad así lo recordó
el presidente chileno cuando firmó la
ley
hoy Sin lugar a dudas es un día que es
histórico porque se hace realidad
algo que durante mucho rato nos dijeron
que era imposible
que era un acto de voluntarismo
que era solo para complicar O solamente
para aparecer la prensa pero que esto no
era posible en Chile
que esas eran cosas para Europa
pero que en Chile cómo es posible que se
necesita trabajar mucho más
eso nos decían en ese momento pues de
hecho un estudio de la organización
Internacional del trabajo muestra como
en la práctica del promedio de horas
trabajadas es mucho menor que lo
establecido por la lejía y cuál es el
panorama al respecto en América Latina
según las estadísticas los países como
El Salvador a México o Uruguay encabezan
la lista de más tiempo en el trabajo
mientras que Panamá o Argentina trabajan
menos según la agencia de Naciones
Unidas América Latina trabaja en
promedio 39,3 horas a la semana mucho
menos que en países asiáticos o de medio
oriente Pero esto no quiere decir que se
trabaje poco según los expertos en
nuestros países solamente se miden los
trabajos formales y quedan por fuera los
informales y se deben tomar en cuenta
los altos niveles de informalidad
laboral que existen en la región más del
50% por ello medidas como la chilena
toman relevancia
esto es un es una medida que todo en la
que todos ganan gana el país ganan los
trabajadores y trabajadoras ganan las
los y los empresarios Porque además
están recibiendo apoyo del Estado
mejoran su productividad pero también y
ello lo no lo quiero dejar pasar ganas
los niños y niñas de nuestro país porque
esta es una medida también profamilia
como nosotros mismos lo hemos dicho
considerando que entrega más tiempo a
padres y madres para estar con su hijo
de hecho hay una medida en particular
que quedó en la ley que es la medida de
conciliación de la vida familiar y
trabajo que establece bandas horarias es
decir se contempla la posibilidad de
establecer estas bandas horarias que
permiten un ingreso y salida
diferenciados al trabajo que se han
adaptables a ventanas de horarios hasta
de dos horas de diferencia para poder
utilizarlo por madres o padres o
personas que están a cargo del cuidado
de niños o niñas menores de doce años
creo que esto es un elemento muy
relevante porque también establece un
resguardo de de del cuidado de las
labores de cuidado que ejercemos
fundamentalmente las mujeres y en ese
sentido que dicen los expertos sobre la
calidad de vida y los salarios pues la
idea original de las 48 horas semanales
en la región surgió para dividir el día
en tres franjas ocho horas de trabajo
ocho para la familia y para cosas
personales y ocho para el ocio pero al
pasar de los años la franja se ha sumado
por ejemplo tiempo extra como el que
pasamos en el tráfico para ir y volver
del trabajo sumado a que en América
Latina no existe una relación lineal
entre trabajar más horas a la semana y
ser más productivos incluso muchos
trabajadores prefieren trabajar más
horas para generar más ingresos
interesante esta discusión Daniela sobre
la reducción de las obras laborales
Gracias por estar con nosotros aquí nos
vemos en otra oportunidad nos vemos si
ustedes sigan conectados con France 24
[Música]